where there is three different ways to
contribute one is with your time one is
with your money one is with your voice
if you have a platform talk about it if
you got time give your time to somebody
if you got the money make the right
investments into companies that want to
do something about this and that's what
Elon Musk is doing Elon just spent $100
million I want you to think about this
he put $100 million into a new UN
University Elon wants to open up a new
University in Texas this is according to
the story uh The Verge so Elon Musk
plans to establish a university in
Austin Texas with a $100 million
contribution from his charity the
foundation the university will focus on
stem education and offer instruction in
subjects like math science engineering
and physics it aims to provide Hands-On
learning experiences and simulations
while seeking accreditation from
Southern Association of Colleges and
Schools commissions on colleges in
addition to the university musk's plan
includes building stem focused primary
and secondary school schools that will
teach subject Beyond stem these K
through 12 schools will initially enroll
around 50 students with the intention of
scaling up over time this is an example
of somebody that's making their money
and using their money to fight the
elites when you see Elon doing something
like this Tom for somebody whose
daughter we cannot publicly say it yes
or no we cannot say it or we can't say
it don't say the school don't say the
school okay Tom's daughter had a school
she wanted to go to yeah I'll give you
where it's at it's in America okay that
narrows
it specific it's not Oxford no it's not
Oxford she got a 1560 out of her 1600 as
a parent time when you hear somebody
like Elon Musk who's got few hundred
billion dollar he's putting $100 million
into schools what does that make you
think about because if he's the pay
Setter maybe other people are going to
say I want to start my my own school as
well what does this make you think about
well this this Mak to think about and I
I've had this discussion with my
daughter and my wife and I said I think
you're the last generation that goes at
least from our family into a traditional
education institution as we know the
structure today I don't think my
grandkids would do this I think that you
have people like Elon Musk like you and
me that feel passionate about education
that are going to build a Next
Generation a next level of Education in
America and what I think about I really
think this is the the last generation at
least I'm going to be involved with that
that goes to these traditional colleges
in a traditional way and and by the way
it's really sketchy right now you know
but she's got a specific major she wants
to go follow that but that's what I
think about I got a question and I love
what he's doing I love what he's doing I
want to support him let's be creative
let's be creative and let's get some
ideas here okay let's just say we have
an unlimited checkbook we can use some
of our resources to start a school what
would you build as a school to be unique
and different than other schools out
there how would you build a school what
would you do in your school this goes to
everybody here Tom I'll start off with
you I I'd go right back to the tradition
of debate because debate has become you
know just loud argument there was a
tradition of debate where you had a
elegant way and there was rules of
debate to come bring in a point have a
Counterpoint a rebuttal and then a
review by your peers at the conclusion
of that debate called the discussion of
your of your classmates or a discussion
by a panel I would bring back debate of
both sides bringing both sides in so
people could see the logic and the true
winner rather than being told who the
winner is Vinnie what would you do I
mean I remember what pledge allegiance
they took did they take that out of
school too just something in the
beginning where you where you shot out
your country and you you basically get
everybody on the same team they stopped
doing all that Charlie you got a school
we're whatever we want to call the
school we can call it what would you
have in your school that would be
different than other schools yeah first
I think Hillsdale does a great job uh
and I think Hillsdale is America's
greatest college and they're a sponsor
here and I I love them hillsdale.edu
they're amazing actually the website is
Charlie for hillsdale.com if you really
want to check it out but um I would make
a different I I would I would combine
Mind Body Soul um if the theoretical
school is you have to be physically fit
uh you have to have a certain BMI you
have to commit to a spiritual life and
you also have to develop your mind and I
would do it in a classical way uh the
whole Center of higher education should
be that there is a truth and let's
figure out what that is the reason the
woke stuff has started is they start
from a truth claim saying there is no
truth as soon as you acknowledge there's
an objective of Truth in the universe it
destroys all woke I hope everyone
understands that how do you beat the
woke as soon as you get people to
acknowledge that there are natural laws
of the universe that transcend Your
Existence and some things are
objectively true it it absolutely o
obliterates the woke so as higher
education has dismissed that the woke
has been ascendant so that's what I
would do Adam let's by the way how many
you guys want to hear what Adam has to
say about the school anybody wants to
hear Adam's thoughts here what would you
do with your school so I have a feeling
what if Adam started a school yeah 9010
ratio I believe 100% you not it' be like
a nightclub in Miami 90% women 10% guys
it's going to be the best college of all
time but with that being said number
rule number one rule number one no dudes
are allowed to play sports with the
females I like that straight up I like
that okay like just not happening very
unque idea this is like man that's
understand you're saying if we will do
like we did back in the day in Little
League Cup check let's see what's going
on here got you number two when we
started the podcast in 2020 I think the
number was like 11 to1 liberal teachers
yep versus conservative teachers that's
right 11 to1 can we just get that back
to an equilibrium situation where
there's an equal amount like you talked
about debate conservatives liberals talk
to each other because what's going on
with these smartest useful idiots in the
world at Harvard MIT pen we're seeing
what's going on there these kids are
geniuses but they're being fed a ball of
crap from these teachers because because
how many kids in college are actually
going to stand up and confront their
teacher on maybe some ideology that they
perceive as wrong they're going to shut
the f up and follow along and then just
go along that path so I think it's
problematic that there's so many
teachers that are just basically
indoctrinating kids there's no more
education as just indoctrination in
school now back in Florida State when I
was there playing ball having fun we
didn't really have to get into all this
uh woke situation they go to class at
Florida State no but Charlie that's how
you up a podcast with TVD and Pat Pat I
think especially in the younger age like
you what what do cops walk around know
that what about Arizona State guy what
are you talking about I didn't go to
college he didn't even go to college
yeah here go to college it's a scam
everybody college is a scam the
university system is broken college is
ridic look like a good book it's called
the college scam the college scam you
did write a book about it P what what do
what do cops wear on their on their Jack
the cameras that body cam the body cam
kids up to a certain age like when
they're young I want body cam all they
have cell phones that's no no no I want
a c like you you as a parent to see what
the hell they're teaching the kids I
totally agree have a have a camera go
like a GoPro on your kid I want to hear
if I want to tap in during the day and
see what the hell you're teaching my kid
I want to be able to come in and watch
here's the best argument you drop your
dog off for Doggy Daycare and you can
log into an app to see if your golden
retriever is being pampered it's getting
abused when you drop your kid off to a
public school you have a moral right to
find out what that teacher is teaching
thank you and Charlie even if it's one
camera in the classroom if like you're a
dad want to sign up for me yeah if
you're a dad in your home Adam I want to
be able to just go okay what are they
doing if you go in there and everybody's
wearing rainbow and dancing around
I'm coming to the school you know what I
mean
Tom CLA what the hell's going on they
want me to put this out there you
go Phoenix welcome to the West
people guys that's the first Middle
Eastern Cowboy ever I
love hey we put the college uh scam
written by Charlie Kirk here you got
your book autograph pbd I want to hear
your answer to this question how would
you you're not going the
college sign but your hair still is good
ask the question no yeah because we've
had this conversation before but I think
with Charlie here and obviously in the
light of this book what would you do
because you have four kids some may go
to college some some might go on a
sports scholarship you've thought about
this I'm going to do one thing that's
going to be slightly different here's
what I'm doing if you go to my school if
if you're kids are going to my school I
need your involvement the parents
involvement period okay if the parent is
not involved your kids can't go to my
school because I'm going to need your
help if we're going to spend time
challenging your kids pushing them
driving them you have a certain
responsibility every month for you to
come to school what do you mean by this
the kid the parents need to come to
school parents are coming like Rodney
Dangerfield and back to school no that's
not what I'm talking about I'm talking
about you're coming to model that works
in the inner city charter school you're
coming to school because we're going to
also work on you becoming
because we're going to become
collectively with the team so we'll
update you hey let me tell you what's
going on here's what happened this week
this is what we're working on these are
the things that we want to talk about
what parents are working hey Johnny can
you tell us what you're doing with your
kids that your two kids that go to our
school they have straight A what are you
doing Mary can you share with us what
you're doing with your kids that they
got straight A as well and then all of a
sudden you're like oh you guys do
that yeah that's a great idea I'm going
to use other parents that are raising
their kids well to develop other parents
that are also holding their kids
accountable this idea about let me send
my kids somewhere you do your thing with
the kids it's parents responsibility so
we would put a bit of the onus also on
the parents the focus will be leadership
development the way he had it I love the
idea but uh can I can I add one more
thing that I think is would be right up
your Alle what's that I think kids need
to understand that their major has an
Roi attached to it and I think they need
to eliminate whatever Majors have no
like kids are going into 50 100,000 A4
million
of debt before they even made a dollar
in their life and it turns out that
basket weaving or underwater sewing I'm
going to tell does not make money you
know it's crazy though here's here's one
thing we're not even thinking about like
look at all the industries that are
about that have disrupted an A P before
okay look what this is okay I never went
to Columbia University to be a you know
podcast or journalist we're here doing a
podcast people watch this millions of
people give their opinions thoughts do
you know some of these guys that are
used to reading a teleprompter right
there yes next today at 8:00 John J from
the and you're just kind of reading it
yeah the disruption did this to
mainstream Media newspapers internet
Twitter social I believe the next 10 20
30 years one of the one of the
industries that's going to be disrupted
in ways we don't even know ourselves is
going to be education and it's going to
be so painful by the way we saw what
happened with MIT we saw what happened
with pen we saw what happened with
Harvard they didn't fired the president
gay right we're not going to be doing
that they redefine plagiarism yesterday
in their bylaws by the way you know what
I love I love that they did that you
know why if you're a parent and you're
still thinking Harvard's the Pinnacle of
school to go to you are a fool this is
not the same Harvard of 20340 years ago
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right
here